هذه هي يدك الروبوتيه هذه هي
وحده لا نوعيه او ام بي ال وهي الذراع
الصناعيه الاكثر تعقيدا في العالم يمكنها
ان تقوم مقام اليد الطبيعيه انه تاكيد
ملفت للنظر اجل بالفعل تحتوي الذراع على
اكثر من 26 مفصلا يمكن التحكم بها عن طريق
التفكير هل يوجد انماط مشابهه لهذه
الزراعه لا هذه الذراع مخصصه للتوافق مع
افكار الدماغ مثل تحكمنا بادروعنا العاديه
عملت جوني ماثيو في مجال الخبز حتى فقد
ذراعه اليسرى التي بطلت لاصابته بالسرطان
عام 2008 وعندما سمع بتجارب الاختبار لليد
الصناعيه هذه سجل في التجارب باسرع وقت
يعادل وزن وحده اليد الصناعيه وزن اليد
البشريه اي ما يقارب 4 كلغ ويمكن لهذه
اليد تقليد اي حركه تقوم بها اليد البشريه
وبمهاره فائقه تتوفر بوجود سته وعشرين
مفصلا ومئه جهاز استشعار بالاضافه الى
سبعه عشر محركا الى جانب كمبيوتر صغير تم
تركيبه في اليد الصناعيه والنتيجه تبدو
منتظمه كمقطوعه موسيقى
الان كيف تشعر
انه نوع من الجنون اشعر بانني من جديد
عندما فقدت يدي في عام 2008 لما اتوقع بان
النساء ارى مثل هذا الاختراع بل توقعت ان
اضع خطافا طوال حياتي لا يمكن ان اصف
شعوري بمثل هذا الاختراع
يجب برمجه اليد بحذر من خلال الكمبيوتر
للتوافق مع الحركات العصبيه الصادره عن
الجزء المبتوري من اليد يمكن لجوني ان
يحرك اليد الصناعيه عندما يفكر بتحريك يده
الطبيعيه التي فقدها مولدا اشارات
كهربائيه يمكن رؤيتها على الشاشه بعدها
يميز الكمبيوتر كل نمط من هذه الاشارات
ويحرك اليد الصناعيه بناء عليها